Aloha ladies and gentlemen my name is is
is Greg Greg album album that's John
wolf Fifty Shades of show your trailer
match Suicide Squad Fifty Shades of Grey
mash-up longtime subscribers is the very
beginning I do name nerdy hero he's calm
he's calming in so much throughout the
years of this channel existing he was
talking to me on Instagram and he told
me about how he had this video that's
getting a lot of attention on movie
sites and such and as guys like 200,000
reviews already so I'm really proud of
him because it's really cool to see a
subscriber who doesn't really have a
channel and now he's like now it's
channels like booming all his video yes
it's not just updated me yeah he
requested it but he's no rats man he
also has a lot of success coming from in
and I was like absolutely dude give it a
longtime supporter I'd be more than
happy to check out your video
we've been intentionally making this
more of a movie related channel sort of
thing that's our thing we want to make
sure we really want to bring it back to
me more of a movie vibe we'll do a
YouTube video reaction to this because
it's movie related so why not mmm okay
cool
you ready for this J Thompson I was born
ready when I woke up today
as dr. Harleen Quinzel psychiatrist at
Arkham Asylum she was assigned to cloud
himself
she thought she was curing me but she
was falling in love
you
talk about workplace romance gone wrong
they became the king queen of Gotham
City disrespected I can't wait to show
you my toys
reenter your Jewish
I'm just gonna hurt you yeah really
really
welcome go subscribe to nerdy hero right
now if you like that video link in the
description box hitting the like button
it's like in the video like you asked
for a nerdy hero we listened so mr. uh
mr. J oh yeah miss what did you think
I know those cool it took me a minute to
get into the groove of what he was doing
because it's not so much a trailer
mashup like I was expecting there to be
like 50 shades of grey like I thought it
would almost be a hybrid of coke clips
yeah yeah I'm kind of be like a parody
and actually what surprised me is like
this looked like a movie I really want
to see now yeah this looked like a like
a fanfiction trailer for a film I would
much rather see just the [ __ ] up
romance of Harley yeah and a joke
because it's actually an interesting
concept because Fifty Shades of Grey is
a concept that has movies that should be
edgy that should have a darkness to it
that should push boundaries and it
doesn't really do that I don't know what
the new movies gonna be like what does
gonna do that forget everything you know
but seeing this it was like yeah like
the Fifty Shades style it's you Joker
and Harley Quinn that would make more
sense because they are a [ __ ] up
relationship we know they're a [ __ ] up
relationship so taking their music and
making it like a trailer style over it
was was a cool idea if anything though
it did make me go like that would be a
great idea for Warner Brothers to do a
Valentine's Day release of a Joker and
Harley Quinn's movie just just do true
true romance but with Joker the project
yeah exactly
yeah I don't think you have natural the
movie itself Suicide Squad download so
obviously you have to like download
clips from the internet to use it but I
feel like if you have the DVD of it and
you were able to like rip the actual
footage you would have had a much
clearer more solid looking video besides
the concept is there
the concept so there I mean yeah this
seems to be your first time doing
something like this and at least for the
first time isn't even in the past six
months and I'm looking at through your
video this year so it's a great job for
a first time it accomplishes its goal
the site despite whatever technical
flaws I might be able to see it John
might be able to see here it still
accomplishes its goal and going I would
be way more excited about a [ __ ] up
romance story of Joker Harley Quinn yeah
over fifty shades of it this looks like
a graphic novel I want to read it and
also you know the BDSM you know
accoutrement Sir Tim means the Joker I
think you should make like a a hard-r
Joker Harley Quinn filming I would like
not honest love to see their sex life
beyond Christian grace Oh gladly see you
with what kind of crazy [ __ ] these two
do I feel like you would get a legit 50
shirts 50 shades of grey yeah I feel
like you get a legit 50 shades of grey
out of this like that does not have to
hold back for anybody and while they're
like you know having sex you can have
like the laughing gas in there yeah yeah
that was really small bad really twisted
yeah oh yeah cuz you know think you know
the Fifty Shades of Grey when he took
that moment Oh like I'm not gonna kill
you I was like how are you good in a sex
scene for a Joker yeah you're a hero man
Congrats on the success of this video
yes this is this is what I wish
superhero movies and start to do as time
goes on because we've seen a lot of the
the archetypical ones and now I want
like comic book characters you know yeah
in this kind of story like I want to see
other kinds of stories with these sorts
of characters alright guys subscribe to
nerdy hero you can watch that video in
full screen on
and the link in the description box
let's go there if you're new to this
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects cover a lot of movie talk John
reasons to Giri is Twitter and Instagram
handle and he is a social media manager
of facebook.com slash Blume house and
facebook.com slash the real rejects
right we're planning on doing some
Facebook stuff so just like our Facebook
page because we're planning on actually
using it with some of our own content
instead of just hosting other people's
stuff and shout out to nerdy hero nerdy
hero let's see there's a video here
where you got to see what you look like
ok you look Filipino I think you're
Filipino
do you like karaoke do you enjoy
jellybeans jellybeans jellybeans is the
Filipino fast-food chain that you will
find here in California oh is that one
jelly actually serve hamburgers there
any time I go to jollibee and I do not
get Filipino food hamburgers and french
fries it's in it and and a coca-cola to
go with like me oh well do they put like
Filipino cuisine [ __ ] on the burger or
as I get a plane we catch up mustard and
lettuce nice Germans